agricultural disasters aren't just about
crops failing they're about lives being
torn apart droughts that last for years
flash floods that destroy entire
harvests and extreme weather events
becoming the new normal and it's not
just nature turning against us our own
practices are accelerating this
crisis over farming
deforestation and the excessive use of
chemical fertilizers are stripping the
land of its
nutrients leaving it vulnerable and
Barren take a look at the dust bowl of
the
1930s a man-made disaster where poor
Land Management and Relentless farming
turned the Great Plains of the United
States into a vast
Wasteland today we Face a similar threat
but on a global scale from Africa's
sahal region to the fertile Plains of
Asia once thriving farmlands are turning
into
deserts but the challenges don't end
there climate change is the Ultimate
Game Changer Rising temperatures
unpredictable rainfall and severe storms
are making farming more challenging than
ever crops that once flourished in
certain C regions are now struggling to
survive forcing Farmers to either adapt
quickly or abandon their lands Al
together this isn't just an
environmental issue it's a humanitarian
crisis as crops fail the Ripple effects
are felt far and wide food prices
Skyrocket and in some areas basic
Staples become scarce imagine walking
into your local grocery store only to
find empty shelves and prices so high
that feeding your family becomes a daily
struggle this is not just a problem for
Farmers it's a problem for all of us but
it's not all doom and gloom around the
world scientists farmers and innovators
are working tirelessly to find
solutions from developing drought
resistant crops to exploring sustainable
farming practices the fight to secure
our food future is
underway Technologies like vertical
farming and hydroponics are
revolutionizing the way we grow food
making it possible to farm in
environments once considered
impossible communities are also rising
to the challenge implementing
regenerative agriculture practices that
restore the soil conserve water and
reduce carbon
emissions these efforts are not just
about survival they're about thriving in
the face of
adversity it's a powerful reminder that
when we work with nature rather than
against it we can overcome even the most
daunting
challenges but the question remains will
we act in time the future of our food
system depends on the choices we make
today join us as we delve deeper into
the causes consequences and solution
solons to agricultural
disasters don't just be a spectator be
part of the
solution subscribe to our Channel hit
that notification Bell and together
let's explore how we can Safeguard our
planet's most precious resource our
ability to feed ourselves
[Music]